it is no matter whether it's your first
vote
or many but beyond that this is the most
important election in our lifetimes you
can make
all the difference here in florida you
can determine the outcome this election
[Music]
we win florida and it's all over
choice is clear the stakes never and
higher
mistakes in this election remind me of
something my dad used to say
you say joey jobs about a lot more in
the paycheck
despite your dignity it's about your
place in the community it's about
being able to look your kidney eye and
say honey everything's going to be okay
and mean it how many people
and look the kids in the eye and say
that today it's going to be okay
i mean it that's the lesson i've never
forgotten
that's why i grew up surrounded by
hard-working folks
in scranton pennsylvania claymont
delaware
[Music]
these times are hard these times are
hard
unemployment is way up to the pandemic
the economic outlook for the next year
remains uncertain
and across florida in the country folks
are worried about
being able to pay their rent their next
mortgage payment
whether or not they can purchase the
prescription they put their or put food
on the table
worried about school and their kids
they see they see the people at the top
doing better and better during this
crisis
i wonder who's looking out for me folks
that's donald trump's presidency 115 000
dead kroger 19.
and experts say unless we change rapidly
in [ __ ]
no indication he's willing to change to
do the proper thing
we could lose another 200 000 lives
the next few months all because this
president
was only worried about the stock market
didn't want to scare anybody
he refused to follow science it's
established
it's estimated that if in fact we all
wore
mass between now and january we could
save
a hundred thousand lives
folks what bothers me the most about
this guy
in his own words the president knew
back in january when he was wreaked in
detail
after lying about it saying he never
read the intelligence community's
warnings
about how dangerous this was what did he
do
he learned in january the end of january
that in fact this was a fairly virus
that it was passed on easily
that it was airborne but he didn't tell
anybody
he went on taking an interview with bob
woodward a journalist
telling him trying to appreciate himself
to him so
he knew how dangerous jesus was back in
january
but he did nothing not a single thing
didn't say word to anybody
ask yourself why didn't he tell the
country
he said nothing but he told woodward
when woodward asked him why didn't send
it he said i didn't want to panic the
american people
american people do not panic donald
trump
americans have faced every problem
that's ever confronted us
and as reckless personal conduct since
the diagnosis
has been unconscionable the longer
donald trump remains
president the more reckless he becomes
three more awakes before we end this
most respected back in the country on
this issue with dr fauci
he referred to the president's
announcement of the supreme court
with a political event in a rose guard
or in the backyard of the
of the white house he called it a super
spreading event
look at all the people became contagious
and got ill
and how is responding now he
trump is running a national ad on
television you may have seen it
taking dr dr fauci out of context
he said dr fauci said way back in march
referring to a public health officials
he said i can't imagine
that anybody could be doing more
referring to the public health officials
across america yet the trump campaign
deliberately lied making it sound as if
how she was talking about
trump how she
went public after the ad came out saying
i did not get permission for that quote
and i wasn't referring to the president
[Applause]
here's the real point about the lack of
ethics
even after faulty said he didn't say
that about trump
the trump campaign said they'll continue
to use the ad
knowing it was a lie folks
i don't recall any administration any
presidential candidate
neither major party doing anything like
that
that behavior is no surprise though
after all it's the same man
who looks at americans with their lives
in the line
for our nation and calls them losers and
suckers
folks i carry with me a card my schedule
card
that lays out in the back my schedule
the last back page
in a black box i carry it every day for
the past 13 years
it says daily troop updates
u.s troops have died in iraq and
afghanistan
6924 at around 6900
924 because every one of these fallen
angels
left behind the entire community
[Music]
church wounded in afghanistan and iraq
53
194 not 53 000 about
folks my son
was one of those who volunteered to go
to iraq for a year
came home and he passed away he was not
a loser
he was an american hearing and all this
congress left behind
they were patriots who the heck does
this guy think he is
and now as a consequence of this
overwhelming line and misleading
irresponsible
on the part of donald trump how many
empty chairs are there
around dinner tables tonight because of
his negligence
how many husbands and wives at night
lean over to touch and say goodnight to
their wife or husband
and they're not there how many people
have holes in their heart and lost part
of their soul
debbie ross when i talk about this how
can we have a guy like this
ladies and gentlemen we're so much
better than this
despite the crisis we face
[Music]
we have an enormous we have an enormous
opportunity
to build this country back better we're
the only nation in the world
with every crisis we've run under we've
ended up better off coming out of it
than we were
before we went in that's because america
there's no
queen in america
an equal chance to get ahead for example
for communities of color in south
florida all across this country question
is
how do we break the cycle we're in good
times you lie behind
and in bad times you get hit first and
the hardest
and recovery comes you're the last ones
to bounce back
the answer is simple justice criminal
justice please reform
i know the nation is strong enough to
both honestly face
systemic racism and strong enough to buy
safe speech for our families
and our businesses that too often bear
the front of looting to burn it
we have no need for armed militias
roaming america streets
and we should have no tolerance for
extremist white supremacist groups
marching on our community
enough i say we should trust american
law enforcement authorities to do their
job
as i do let them do their job without
extremism
[Music]
if you say we have no need to face
racial
justice in this country you haven't
opened your eyes in america
there have been powerful voices for
justice in recent weeks and months
i spent time with george schwartz family
his six-year-old daughter gianna when i
met with her
i knelt down to say hi to her and she
looked at me said
daddy changed the world
daddy changed the world also
take a plate's mother i got to know when
she said that violence didn't reflect
her son
and the nation needed healing and she
prayed
for the police or doc rivers
the basketball coach choking back tears
when he said
vote we're the ones getting killed
we're the ones getting shot we've been
hung
went on to say it's amazing why we keep
loving this country
when this country does not love us back
think about that think about what it
takes
a black person to love america that's a
deep love for this country
that for far too long has god
never fully recognized we need american
leadership
to seek out to de-escalate tensions go
for the lines of communication to praise
together
look ladies and gentlemen it's time
president to heal
heal as president i'll do precisely what
i will do
it's also about jobs good
paying jobs financial stability
families of color building wealth and
passing it down
that's how we deliver our equality and
equity for example
more and more women are dropping out of
the workforce in this recession
whether in the city around the suburbs
we have planned to do with ms pandemic
responsibly tracing testing masking
not politicizing race or vaccine
we have to get vaccines not politicize
it we have to plan
for a safe and economistic view we have
to provide what as of the day is not
happening
funding for protective equipment ppe and
other resources
for hospitals for frontline workers so
the schools can reopen safely
you've got to ease the caregiving prices
and so many families experience
a squeeze of raising your kids and
caring for an aged loved one
got to protect your health care in the
middle of this pandemic
why do republicans have time to hold a
hearing to pack the court
instead of providing significant
economic relief and need for localities
[Music]
it's about wiping out the affordable
care act we're wiping off the books
because their nominees said in the past
that the law
should be struck down that will take
away health care from 20 million
americans
take protections away from existing
conditions over 100 billion people
and by the way kids won't be able to
stay in their
health their parents health insurance
until they're 26
complications like lung scarring
heart damage will become the next crisis
and condition
will toss out toss out the coverage
for so many children it will take us
backwards
insurance companies could charge a woman
money mom remember this but charged a
woman
more for her health care than a man just
because she's a woman from the same
procedure
folks we can do so much better than this
together we'll build on the affordable
care act
[Music]
miami gladiator
a new health insurance option and not
for profit options
don't forget private insurers real
competitors
will increase subsidies agreements lower
costs
to get more coverage lower deductibles
lower out-of-pocket expenses and by the
way
anybody anybody who qualifies for
medicare who lives in a state like your
governor
that doesn't allow for eight hundred
thousand people have it to automatically
be enrolled
we can only do this if we come together
as a country
last week i went to
gettysburg the battlefield of
pennsylvania
abraham lincoln to make a point
we're in trouble abraham lincoln said
there
a house divided cannot stand
today trust is heavy
hope is elusive instead of healing
we're being ripped apart and i refuse to
let that happen
when i ran my announcement i was running
i said i was running one of the
businesses
was to unite america and i was made fun
of they said you can't do that anymore
you used to be able to do it joe
you can't do it now but the only way a
democracy can function is that
consensus otherwise
becomes semi-difficult like this guy's
trying to be
look we need to revive the spirit of
bipartisan with the country's spirit
of being able to work with one of them
well i say that i'm told that that was
fine joe
you used to be able to do that but you
can't do it anymore
well i'm here to tell you we can we must
and we're going to get it done
[Music]
i'm running as a proud democrat
but i will govern as an american
president
[Applause]
[Music]
i work for those who vote against me as
hard as
those who go to foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
have a sacred duty my friend john lewis
who recently passed away would say
it's a sacred obligation to vote
and it matters part of the matter
you elected me and barack obama in 2008
and 2012 and i'm asking for your trusted
sport again
in 2020 for kamala harris and joe biden
[Music]
[Music]
i promise you we will always
have your back i promise you i give you
my word
so please vote and help us get out the
boat
as we mentioned before if you go to
iwillvote.com
fl you can still request
your vote by mail ballot and do it as
soon as you can
you have already a mail you haven't
already mailed you do you have one
bail it drop it in the box today dropbox
today
you can also vote in first starting
october 19th
here in broward county where this
election will be determined
[Music]
country needs you tell everyone to know
everyone you meet
to vote no matter what
i don't want anyone to discourage you to
tell you your voice don't
count it does it will you
are the american people and you will
decide our future
not trump
thank you i had
[Music]
like my friend though
i hadn't planned that this time
my son had passed away i was working as
a
professor i thought enough
but then when i saw those people
coming out of the fields in
charlottesville my word
carrying torches close your eyes
remember to saw
their veins bulging chanting the same
anti-semitic vile very nazi
insignias that were carried and
enchanted
in germany in the 30s accompanied by the
ku klux klan
the white supremacist david duke the
grand priebel
saying this is why we elected him
and then a young woman protesting was
killed
they went to the president united states
and they sent mr president
what do you think here's what he said
something no president in american
history has ever said
he said quote there were very
fine people on both sides
god almighty
what i realized and i said at the time
we are literally in the battle for the
soul of this country
for our decency our honor our compassion
who we
are we hold these truths to be
self-evident
but all men and women are folks we've
never fully lived up to that
we've never walked away from them every
generation has opened the aperture wider
it's the first present ever just flat
walk away from
it's time to score america's soul
it's time to rebuild the backbone of
america the middle class
it's time to bring everybody around no
matter your race your age your gender
your ethnicity your sexual orientation
or your disability
it's time to unite america
we will do that by choosing hope over
fear by choosing science over fiction
truth over lives and unity over division
there's nothing beyond the capacity of
this nation
when we stand together so time to stand
up
take back this democracy when i was a
kid
john kennedy said we're going to the
moon
everybody remembers we all i learned
what he said about that the speech
there's one line that i always used on
the 7th floor when i was a senator
my colleagues would kid me and he
answered the unasked question
why are we doing this he said because i
refuse to postpone
i refuse to postpone one more day
this president's responsible action
let's get up let's take back this
country
show the world who we are and god bless
you and may god
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
got to make
[Music]
is
[Music]
youngest child
you